bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 9
septembre merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition de votre journal
d'information on commence avec les
titres de votre actualité locale près de
80 réfugiés venus de syrie et d'irak
viennent d'arriver dans les yvelines à
l'initiative de l'association habitat et
humanisme
ils sont accueillis abonnés l'abrité au
monastère désoriente la croix rouge a
pris la logistique d'accueil en charge
nous y étions
le département danse aujourd'hui ces
assises de la ruralité sont 60 des 262
communes du département compte moins de
1000 habitants les élus ne possède de
vastes territoires ruraux mais comment
se passe la cohabitation avec lotus
tissu urbain c'est ce que nous verrons
enfin il faudra attendre 2017 pour voir
le chantier de la rd 30 à plaisir
terminé d'ici là les travaux se
poursuivent
il faudra prendre son mal en patience
que l'on soit riverains ou
automobilistes de points à suivre
transport toujours et le réaménagement
du quartier de la gare de la verrière
qui se précise ce soir dans quelques
heures c'est la réunion d' enquête
publique sur le doublement du pont fut
l'heure qui assure la liaison avec
maurepas un axe de passage régulièrement
engorgés et pour en parler je reçois fit
plus claire de la direction des
mobilités de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui est en
charge du dossier
on saura vous nous parlerons de ce sujet
dans quelques instants nous y
reviendrons mais avant cela parlons de
l'actualité du jour l'accueil du jour
c'est la france qui a accueilli ses
premiers réfugiés syriens et irakiens
dans les yvelines 78 personnes sont
arrivées dans la commune de bonnel
depuis munich en allemagne
prise en charge par la préfecture et
l'association habitat et humanisme
ils ont été placés dans la paroisse
dorante où ils seront logés pendant un
mois en attendant le traitement de leur
demande d'asile
williams elle et qu'elle me lambert
était sur place ils ont assisté à
l'arrivée de ces réfugiés regarder
fatigués par leur long voyage mais le
sourire aux lèvres ces réfugiés
expriment leur joie
chacun sa façon
soixante dix huit réfugiés sont arrivés
à bonnel cet après-midi en bus depuis
munich 47 syrien 30 irakien et un
palestinien
leur arrivée au monastère dorante marque
la fin d'un très long périple pour
certains nous avons usé de tous les
moyens de transport voiture bateau de
sauvetage s'arrache et ça va pas après
ce long voyage et après tous ces
kilomètres et ces pays est ce que le
monde a vu à budapest
c'est le début d'une victoire pour nous
d'être ici en sécurité en partenariat
avec la préfecture c'est l'association
habitat et humanisme qui a préparé leur
arrivée dans ce monastère
une opération qui s'organise depuis deux
mois deux familles étaient du voyage
avec trois enfants qui vont enfin
pouvoir apprécier le confort d'un prédit
son échange qui sont petites sans doute
trois petits tas mais entre ce qui est
des personnes inconnues et puisqu'il
aurait proposé aujourd'hui en fait c'est
comme le temps c'est maintenant une
lumière en faites pas pour seule pensée
personnes c'est un lieu de prendre soin
d'un lieu de prendre soin il faut que
les gens qui ont souffert ces dix mais
finalement l'accueil qu'on reçoit
c'est un cas un accueil qui marque un
autre gars en fait du respect après un
court discours de bienvenue les réfugiés
ont rejoint le réfectoire pour prendre
leur premier repas chaud dans les jours
qui viennent seront soutenus dans leur
demande d'asile en préfecture
cet après midi priorité l'accueil humain
si vous permettait ce terme
ces deux
de savoir quels sont leurs besoins vous
avez vu il ya deux familles
mais quel besoin ils ont particuliers
qui prennent possession des lieux de
leurs chambres des lieux communs qui
mange un peu là déjà
et dès demain matin évidemment et de
manière accélérée renforcer tout ce qui
est accueil administratif demandeurs
d'asile demande d'asile et s'était
réfugié dans le laps de temps le plus
court possible
soixante places pourrait s'ajouter aux
80 déjà disponibles les réfugiés
devraient rester ici pendant un mois en
attendant de trouver une solution plus
durable
mais pour eux c'est déjà un énorme
soulagement
nous sommes en ligne avec bernard devert
président de l'association habitat et
humanisme
bonsoir à vous nous l'avons vu dans le
reportage qui vient de suivre
nous avons vu justement donc s'émeut
réfugiés arrivés à 13h30 pouvez vous
nous dire comment se portent ces hommes
et ces femmes quand s'est passée leur
arrivée alors arrivés et des hommes et
des femmes qui sont des fatigués par
leur voyage en partie 022 unique vers
23h30 avec une heure et demie
effectivement abonnés bon et puis au
delà des voyages des hommes et des
femmes qui ont dû quitter leur pays
une avant d'allumer qui avaient des
enfants c'est ça d'être petite cuillère
en raison de l'austérité que chacun
connaît bien que malheureusement entre
le sujet c'est effectivement guaino
recevaient leur offrir in hospitality
comment se passer d'une hostilité à une
heure cutanées
vous avez mis deux mois organisée
justement cette arrivée à pour les
accueillir commence à s'organiser un
petit peu avec la cité l'organisation
qui était faite avec l'état les avis des
rita avec les associations il avait
aussi la croix-rouge n'y a pas invités
m'a dit que j'ai reçues il ya aussi la
croix-rouge qu'un des chiens l'a comme
la commune le maire s'est aussi entendu
le maire qui démarque véritablement une
volonté de ddd des familles qu'elles
sont les premières choses que donc ces
réfugiés vous ont demandé en premier
côté la première chose que dont ils
n'ont pas d'abord demandé ils ont dit
merci important de souligner c'est avant
toute demande et ils ont dit merci merci
pouvoir finalement vous avez vu une
personne qui a fait baisser club était
le sol et il en fait j'ai témoigné que
finalement ce sol c'était pour elle
cette possibilité en fait de pouvoir
revivre et non le fils à jo n'a peur de
ces hommes et de ces femmes le des
familles en fait ils veulent une
espérance extrêmement forte pour quitter
des lieux qui ont été souvent tragiques
les dossiers parfois des fils de la
famille
en effet publiquement de la famille de
la famille aussi qui est décédé que
c'était un site en fait à des attentats
donc il ya un lieu en fait la foire ont
depuis pour beaucoup d'entre eux ils
vont pouvoir vivre en alu voudront pas
la canette d'afida de deux violons bien
sûr voilà ce que c'est vraiment une
bonne chose de les accueillir c'est un
lieu de repos pour eux ce que vous savez
comment on va se passer justement les
prochains jours quel va être le
quotidien de c2c 60 de réfugiés
les prochains jours là le mois à venir
alors ça va leclerc va être marqué par
beaucoup d'interventions je veux voir
l'intervention de l'état demain matin
donc en fait ils veulent avoir ils vont
contre de chaque de ces personnes ou un
harnais sur sa situation le personnel
ils vont passer d'un statut en fait ce
que c'est un studio à 2003 un statut du
réfugié donc une possibilité en fait de
retrouver dans une normalisation fait au
sein de notre pays on soit sept premiers
c'est le premier plan il ya plus qu'une
attention sur les questions de la jante
et donc la présence de la croix rouge
avait une personne qui est descendue
dunkerque
effectivement il a fallu mettre une à
terme donc actuellement et à l'hôpital
ça restera donc à la fois il ya un
prendre soin il ya du vent a tourné et
du aussi pour les tours tous merci merci
beaucoup à bernard devert d'avoir
répondu à notre question nous suivrons
bien sûr cette actualité chien au revoir
ce sont donc les premiers réfugiés qui
sont arrivés dans les yvelines la france
commence à prendre des dispositions pour
accueillir ces populations qui suivent
qui fuient massivement le conflit syrien
c'est un premier pas mais qu'en est il
après l'accueil comment aider ces
réfugiés qui arrivent en france c'est la
question que nous vous que nous vous
avons posé regarder ce qu'on peut 2
c'est compliqué j'ai l'impression et je
pense qu'il faut réfléchir à comment on
peut le faire pour le mieux dans leur
intérêt dans l'intérêt de tout le monde
dans ce qu'il faut c'est bien prévoir ce
qui va mieux parce que c'est pas terminé
et on aimerait que des politiques
prennent sa recharge et commence à voir
des discussions sérieuses pour la suite
je ne sais pas parce que la france va
pas accueillir tout le monde
on a des enfants qui ont ils dit choqué
ont été au chômage et tout et puis on se
retrouve avec cette masse de personnes
qu'on peut pas les aider
maintenant faut pas oublier non plus les
sdf quoi aussi en france donc il faut
arriver à jongler vraiment avec les deux
ans 8 des logements libye en un où c'est
mon père aussi des gens qui se sont
donné veulent aussi également dans
l'actualité de ce mercredi 9 septembre
le conseil départemental lance les
assises de la ruralité des assises pour
mieux répondre aux problématiques que
rencontrent les ruraux une consultation
que pierre bédier son président souhaite
la plus large possible
il ne veut pas que ses habitants soit
ouf les oublier et se réfugie dans un
vote contestataire
les précisions de maxime le maine selon
l' agence départementale in généré 9 %
de la population yvelinoise vie dans des
communes rurales
quelles sont leurs préoccupations leurs
inquiétudes et surtout comment y
répondre
c'est tout l'intérêt des assises de la
ruralité lancé le 9 septembre
elles se dérouleront en trois temps
forts concertation de novembre à
décembre
analyse de janvier à février et enfin
restitution en mars
on entend les problématiques qui se
posent on nous parle de transport on
nous parle d'eux
chez moi il ya une problématique de
parcs ou de parking autour des gares on
nous parle de beaucoup de sujets donc on
a bien une idée de ce qui peut sortir
mais on ne ne filtre pas
on n'impose pas de sujet au démarrage de
ces réunions la parole est vraiment
libre on veut vraiment prendre le pouls
de la ruralité
selon pierre bédier la ruralité est
troublée bien qu'ils se défendent d'être
dans une démarche électoraliste
il confesse en substance une certaine
inquiétude quant à la présence d'élus fn
sur près de la moitié des cantons
yvelinois au deuxième tour des élections
départementales
il s'agit de dire que à l'occasion des
élections les habitants ils expriment
une colère donc il faut essayer de
comprendre cette colère de l'analyser on
peut pas dire que ce soient des sujets
d'immigration qui est marquée ces
cantons il n'y a pas de tradition
industrielle qui est justifié la venue
d'une population migrante
donc c'est pas ça le sujet donc quel est
le sujet et si on veut bien comprendre
pour essayer d'apporter des réponses
agriculteurs chasseurs habitants élus
l'ensemble des yvelinois ruraux sont
invités à prendre part à ces assises
cinq réunions publiques sont prévues la
première aura lieu le 6 novembre à 20
heures à l'hippodrome de rambouillet est
à présent un point circulation avec leur
la rentrée le retour des vacances vous
êtes nombreux à retrouver les travaux
mais aussi les embouteillages de la rd
30 à plaisir cet axe majeur des yvelines
est régulièrement saturé dans la
traversée de plaisir le chantier a
commencé en janvier 2015
où en est il à présent voici un petit
état des lieux des montagnes de sable de
la plage c'est la nouveauté constaté par
les automobilistes qui retrouve la rd30
après les vacances les embouteillages il
y en a toujours mais ils le savent c'est
pour la bonne cause
je pense que c'était nécessaire j'espère
que ça va ça va fluidifier le trafic par
la suite
c'est un petit peu encombré ouais c'est
vrai que il y avait tout le temps du
monde en fait à n'importe quelle heure
c'était encombré du changement il y en a
déjà sur l'échangeur de la nationale 12
le sens de circulation nord-sud se fait
sur des voies aménagée pour l'occasion
entre la rue jules renier et la venue du
pressoir les automobilistes circulent
dans les deux sens sur une chaussée
provisoire pistes fermées itinéraire
dévié les piétons et cyclistes ne
peuvent plus accéder à leurs itinéraires
habituels enfin sur le giratoire du
petit saint cloud la circulation est
réduite à deux fils des désagréments
inévitable notamment
pour les plaisirs ouah ça quelques
petites conséquences forcément de
proximité de l'habitation puisqu'il ya
du bruit quand même iata poussière donc
on en est conscient mais comment faire
autrement mais en tout cas au niveau de
la circulation et des bouchons ça n'a
absolument pas amplifiée d'après ce
qu'on dit et les retours que j'ai des
difficultés s'était précédemment en
place les travaux n'impacte pas
seulement les habitants de plaisir
trente mille automobilistes passent ici
chaque jour
coût du chantier estimé 80 millions
d'euros un enjeu de taille pour le
département c'est une relation majeur
sur deux axes de circulation et il
fallait relier la départementale 113
l'autoroute a13 et la nationale 12 entre
les deux vous avez un barreau c'est le
sait les 30 fin des travaux annoncé à
l'été 2010 est dès le mois de décembre
des perturbations plus importantes
devraient être constatés et nous
continuons à part les transports avec
notre invité philippe leclerc de la
direction des mobilités à la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines alors dans
deux heures une réunion enquête publique
va se tenir sur le raccordement du pont
schuller qui va relier maurepas à la
verrière c'est un projet qui a tendu
depuis une dizaine d'années ce qu'on
peut nous expliquer en quelques mots
justement ce grand projet c'est un
projet qui effectivement est déjà été
engagés quelque part il ya plus
longtemps encore puisque on a
on a des réserves foncières qui ont été
effectuées déjà du temps de la
construction de la ville nouvelle
donc il ya il ya eu en 2007 une étude de
desserte de transport en commun en site
propre sur l'ensemble du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
et c'est dans le cadre de cette étude
est la prolongation de des aménagements
que voit le jour où que verra le jour en
tout cas en 2018 le
le pont schuller qui est une première
séquence en préfiguration de l'ensemble
de ce dispositif de transport en commun
qui vous n'expliquez voilà en quelques
mots les travaux et en quoi cela va
consister qu'est-ce que ça va changer
également pour les habitants alors un
transport en commun en site propre c'est
quoi ces c'est une infrastructure
routière en fait destiné à privilégier
la circulation des bus pour déjà
faciliter le report modal des
automobilistes vers les transports en
commun et puis donc ça n'est pas
seulement un projet lié au but puisque
on en profite pour développer également
des aménagements cyclables donc une
piste cyclable de nouveaux trottoirs
on sécurise l'ensemble des déplacements
et en fluidifie également l' axe du
boulevard schuller puisque des
aménagements de voirie sont destinés à
contourner en particulier la gare de la
verrière
donc il va y avoir plusieurs étapes
savatan une deux étapes les travaux ont
commencé en 2017
les travaux débutent débuteront
effectivement en 2017 pour une durée
d'un peu moins de deux ans de 18 mois
donc se termineront normalement à
l'automne 2018 donc les objectifs ces
voix-là fluidifie fluidifier les
transports pour les automobilistes les
piétons également que ça se passe mais
aussi il ya une question
environnementale là dedans oui il ya une
question environnementale s'éteint c'est
un projet qui est soumis à une étude
d'impact environnemental de par
l'ampleur des travaux 1 donc
il ya un enjeu de santé publique
également puisque c'est un aménagement
qui encore une fois désengorgera la
devrait désengorger la circulation sur
ce secteur qui est fortement empreint de
lassitude la circulation automobile
puisqu'on est en contact direct avec la
rn 10 donc il ya des vrais enjeux
environnementaux a priori l'étude
d'impact qui a été menée sur ce projet
montre qu' il ya des effets très
positifs sur l'environnement et sur la
santé des gens une dernière question à
philippe leclercq chantier s'élève à
plus de 11 millions d'euros
on a vu beaucoup d'argent est aussi
engagé dans les travaux de la rd 30 à
plaisir comment expliquer cela alors que
von et voilà dans une période où les
communes les communautés d'agglomération
doivent surveiller de près leur budget
alors on a on a bénéficié d'un contexte
favorable
il ya le temps de l'action publique
encore une fois c'est un projet qui
arrivait à maturité aujourd'hui on a dix
ans l'intérieur d'antériorité donc il ya
une vraie continuité dans
une cohérence pour faire aboutir ce
projet il ya également durant ces deux
dernières années une forte mobilisation
de nos partenaires financeurs que sont
l'état le conseil général et la région
qui viennent abonder donc que dans le
financement de cette infrastructure
donc les transports voilà c'est un enjeu
principal en ce moment notamment dans le
département des yvelines
merci philippe leclercq d'être venu en
plateau et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
je rappelle que la réunion a lieu ce
mercredi à 20 heures à l'hôtel de ville
de mort pas nous y reviendrons dans
notre édition de demain
un mode économie à présent c'est une
réussite économique madinani pline
générique la marque de produits
capillaires poursuit son expansion
entreprise familiale a son siège social
à paris
les entrepôts et les bureaux sont eux
dans les yvelines et plus précisément à
méré près de montfort l'amaury depuis un
mois ni un nouvel entrepôt a ouvert ses
portes
un reportage de mélanie potesses 5000
mètres carrés c'est la surface du nouvel
entrepôt de génériques
la marque yvelinoise de produits
capillaires low cost lancé en 2004
ça grandit à nouveau l'objectif de cette
société ses 15 ans 15 millions
nous sommes dans la onzième année
aujourd'hui on a besoin d' espaces donc
aujourd'hui on peut aller chercher les
15 millions avec ce nouveau bâtiment qui
est
entièrement automatisé on a essayé de
faire beaucoup de choses pour que mon
travail de plus en plus vite faut
répondre aux demandes de clients
l'entreprise de 23 salariés on voit
quatre à cinq mille colis par mois
le nouvel entrepôt le troisième pour la
marque a ouvert le 7 septembre dernier
est composé de 15 personnes à travailler
quinze personnes qui sortent à peu près
300 à 350 colis par jour génériques
fournis 5000 salon de coiffure en france
pour l'année 2015 l'entreprise prévoit
un chiffre d'affaires de 9 millions
d'euros
et en cette contrée vous le savez on
parle beaucoup de l'environnement c'est
au coeur de l'actualité on parlait
normalement de la convention cadre de
l'onu sur les changements climatiques
qui va se dérouler à paris à la fin du
mois de novembre
mais vous êtes nombreux à vous demander
que faire un niveau plus modeste pour
l'environnement
pour nous en parler en plateau ce soir
avec nous mélanie poquet journalistes de
la rédaction de télé 68 bonsoir mais la
mission bonsoir floral alors oui le
respect de l'environnement passe aussi
par des gestes simples à réaliser chez
soi comme trier ses déchets fermer ses
consommations d'énergie mais aussi
réaliser ses propres produits
d'entretien et il existe des recettes
la recette du jour c'est un produit
nettoyant multi usages que vous pourrez
utiliser dans votre salle de bain votre
cuisine mais aussi c'est les pièces à
vivre
pour cela rien de plus simple il vous
faut de l'eau du vinaigre blanc du
bicarbonate de sodium et des huiles
essentielles arbre à thé de citron de
cannelle en fonction de vos goûts et vos
envies
un contenant celui que nous utiliserons
ce soir fait 250 millilitres un petit
entonnoir et une cuillère à café
yat-il quels sont les avantages en fait
à réaliser ses propres produits soi même
à la nz alors bien sûr il ya des
avantages écologiques et économiques
c'est en tout cas ce que nous a expliqué
maureen note chargée de mission à
l'association y situer à trappes
ll a réalisé les recettes sur les images
une l'entonnoir sur le contenant on y
verse 2 cuillères à café de bicarbonate
vous remplissez quasiment entièrement le
contenant avec de l'eau ensuite vous
ajoutez la cuillère à café de vinaigre
blanc
trois gouttes d'huile essentielle à
rajouter si vous le souhaitez et vous
secouez le tout le tour est joué
si jamais vous voulez utiliser un
contenant d'un litre vous utiliser une
cuillère à soupe par honte
il faut préciser que pour commencer sa
recette il faut bien nettoyer tous ces
ustensiles
et bien respecté l'ordre pour éviter
qu'il y ait des réactions un petit peu
bizarre
justement est ce qu'il ya des dangers
pour la santé mélanie il n'y a
absolument aucun souci à craindre pour
les habitants que ce soit les êtres
humains ou les animaux il faut porter
par contre une petite attention sur les
huiles essentielles
il faut les éviter quand il ya de jeunes
enfants si vous êtes enceinte ou que
vous allaitez et il faut aussi tester le
produit sur les surfaces avant derrière
sur la végétation et notamment la
végétation aquatique en fait sur
certains produits qu'on trouve dans le
commerce notamment tout ce qui est des
poussières de canalisations il ya ce
petit pictogramme qui signifie tout
simplement physiquement ça peut être
dangereux néfastes pour l'environnement
et milieux aquatiques
alors si vous souhaitez découvrir
d'autres recettes l'association propose
des ateliers
toutes les informations se trouvent sur
le site qui s'affiche actuellement en
bas de votre écran
et si mal et on ne trouve pas le temps
de faire cette recette qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire qui est un petit geste pour
l'environnement qu'on peut quand même
faire soi-même et ben oui parce que dans
le commerce on trouve aussi des produits
écologiques
ils sont reconnaissables à des logos
pour les identifier l'ademe l'agencé de
l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie a réalisé plusieurs brochures
à l'écran vous pouvez voir ce que
l'agent s'appelle déjà
les incontournables org alors voilà
floral il ne vous reste plus qu'à
franchir le pas eh bien merci nani je
vais y réfléchir en tout cas chez vous
n'hésitez pas à tester cette recette est
peut être à partager vos distances avec
mélanie qui vous répondra sur twitter
vous verrez bien si la recette
fonctionne ou pas ce cas merci à mélanie
pour cette chronique on vous retrouve
tous les mercredis dans le journal et
bien sûr dès le 25 septembre pour
équilibre le magazine de l'environnement
et de l'environnement à la culture il
n'y a qu'un pas dans le cadre de
l'anniversaire du tricentenaire de la
mort du roi soleil
une exposition a été conçue au château
de breteuil autour de louis xiv et
l'introducteur des ambassadeurs louis
nicolas baron de breteuil sont
rassemblés des manuscrits avec les
mémoire de celui qui fut en 1699 le
responsable des relations officielles
entre louis xiv et les puissances
étrangères
plus de précisions à suivre dans kiosque
l'émission culturelle de cette semaine
et je le rappelle
l'information principale de cette
édition l'arrivée dans les yvelines 2 78
réfugier dans la commune de bonnel ces
réfugiés qui viennent de munich en à
main en allemagne par dont ils ont été
prises en charge par la préfecture et
l'association habitat et humanisme ainsi
que la croix rouge
ils sont accueillis dans la paroisse
dort en tout ils seront logés pendant un
mois en attendant le traitement de leur
demande d'asile
une actualité dont nous reparlerons dès
demain et tout de suite rester avec vous
restez avec nous ne ratez pas la
première émission de clauses que
l'émission culturelle présentée par
sephora namani c'est maintenant la fin
de notre édition je vous donne rendez
vous demain pour une nouvelle édition de
notre journal d'information en direct à
18h il ne me reste plus qu'à vous
souhaiter une excellente soirée